i don't think anyone was surprised that
carrie lam wasn't going to seek a second
term since hong kong's fifth wave uh has
derailed its covert zero efforts it's
been pretty clear her political days are
numbered however people were surprised
that she said that she told beijing she
wasn't going to run in march 2021 at the
national people's congress since then
carrie lam has unveiled a 10-year plan
for housing at her public address last
october and she gave an interview with
local media which called her the
comeback queen so people had expected
that she was going to run until the
recent wave so
you know i think it was more her
timeline was the surprise
well you know there are people who say
you know beijing is running the city
anyway so who cares who's the chief
executive but i do think it will matter
what perspective the next candidate
brings so local media have reported over
the weekend that john lee is
about to announce his candidacy he's a
career cop he brings a very strong
national security mandate to the role if
he stands on the other side people are
also speculating that financial
secretary paul chan might run that would
steer the city to a much more kind of
pro-business leaning so people are
really seeing this as a pivotal election
which direction hong kong goes in
towards police state or pivoting back to
its financial hub status
[Music]
you